once we prove this result let me show
you where we're going to be going okay
we're gonna have a result it's very very
concise and there are two main
applications that we're gonna explore in
this is probably worth jotting down in
14 F of the year 11 textbook there are
too many applications one of them is
pure and the other one is can't tell me
what the other big branch of mathematics
is apart from pure well we're really
asleep this morning okay when we do mass
for its own sake that's called pure mass
it's like we're not trying to solve any
problems we're just like playing around
that and see what happens right but the
other kind of math is where you trying
to solve a problem it's good apply it to
specific contexts and it's called apply
it thank you very much so there are some
pure problems that we can solve with
this rosamma free there are some applied
problems we can solve but interestingly
and actually this is often the case it's
going to be the pure result that becomes
more interesting to us because it's
going to take us into calculus of
trigonometric functions okay so we're
going to focus on those top two because
that's where you need to sort of bed
things down before you get into calculus
but this is just so you know where the
trajectory is headed so hopefully by now
I've stored a little bit and you have
drawn for you a I sector and I've got a
triangle within that and because this is
a sector it's part of a circle right
that's I'm one of the signals to you
that even though I'm doing trigonometry
as a whole I'm working in these angles
right but the angles are not just going
to be in any form it's within the
context of a circle so when you see
circles and you see angles which form of
angle are you going to use which method
of measuring are you going to use
degrees you're going to try and get away
from degrees as much as you possibly can
sometimes you can't but because this is
a circle that should indicate to you
that everything we're about to do is in
radians okay and that's actually very
important later on because when we start
doing calculus as a treadle metric
function one of the key things is how
we're doing this all in radians you'll
think why why are we doing this is some
arbitrary theme we'll all the results on
which calculus with trig functions
depend we're about to do this morning
and because they're based on radians
everything following this is also gonna
be rated okay now you guys know in maths
frequently we gain knowledge from
looking at a single object from more
than one perspective okay thing
back to come on he takes it I think back
to auxilary angle you guys already
covered exhilarate go right yep so the
whole idea is if I give you a function
that is the sum of two other treated
metric functions you can write it in a
new form you can say okay I'm going to
have a new wave function out of these
two it's going to have a different
amplitude and it's also going to have a
different what's the other thing is
going to change so know it starts with a
P you guys learnt this word yet it's
going to have a different phase thank
you very much right so when you take
your wave function it's the same wave
function same amplitude but if you shift
it along horizontally we call that the
phase right now these are the two same
thing they're the same object right but
we like this because you're like a
single trig function I can deal with
this much easier so you've got the same
object looked at from two angles and you
gain insight right are we going to do
exactly the same thing when this is
within this diagram and you can see the
object I'm interested in because I've
highlighted with color right this sum
this H here is what we're interested in
and we're going to look at it from two
very simple perspectives and therefore
gain some information out of this now
I've never really left some stuff off
here which I want you to add along with
me okay to get at this H over here to
look at it from two different
perspectives I want to focus on this guy
down here see this little length between
our vertical lathe and our arc over here
this guy is going to be important so
we're going to call him X right now
little like this X now because along the
bottom here this is the edge of a sector
right if this is X what does this
remaining length end up being minus X
right it's just that difference there
okay so far so good I've done all my
setup now I'm ready to actually
understand this thing that red object
there exists in a right angle triangle
and I know that angle that's subtended
at the center of this big circle of
which I haven't drawn the whole thing so
therefore I can stay H in terms of well
in terms of variety of trig functions
I've got three to choose from but I'm
actually going to be for reasons clear
in about ten minutes I'm only gonna
focus on sign in turn can someone tell
me what statement can I make with H that
has sign in it I'll give you a clue it
starts with science tell me what I can
write next
you've only got one angle in this
triangle right so maybe I should take
sine of theta Wow
it's almost as if I've given you
information that leads you in this trick
to a particular direction in this
triangle triangle sine theta of course
is equal to opposite on hypotenuse okay
now this is true but remember I told you
the object I'm really focusing on is
actually that H right so I'm gonna
change the subject here and I get H
equals R sine theta out of that I use so
far so good okay so I have a statement
for the length of H but that's not the
only perspective from which I can look
I'm gonna write a stable with ten in it
I'm gonna give you a second you go ahead
you write it down I'm not going to do it
together you guys can work this part out
okay Chester what do we got okay H minus
X opposite on adjacent or fine but again
remember the thing I'm really interested
in is H so I'm going to change that to
be the subject and this is what I get
okay now nothing particularly
groundbreaking so far but you notice
that I have the same length H and stated
in two different ways so I can actually
equate this right I can say therefore R
sine theta and r minus X tan theta these
are the same thing just look that in two
different ways okay now why would I
bother doing this well see my diagram
see how it's so comically large right
the reason it's comically large is
because I use this meter rule for this
very specific reason okay and if you've
got your ruler they're also gonna pop it
down here I'm gonna pop it down the mt
just so you can see all my actually I'll
put on top you can still see my X in my
R minus X there there we go there's one
there's my radius in yellow and then
here's my other radius now what I've got
here no I am gonna have to put a lot
what I've got here
that's better are these two radio and
I'm interested in what happens when the
angle gets smaller hence the heading
small-angle approximations okay so as
theta gets smaller as it shrinks down
okay
this radius is not going to be up here
anymore it's going to be at spots like
say that yeah that'll do me
okay now can you see as theta gets
smaller this is like fina which is like
half the lane okay what's going to
happen is this H is going to change its
position has changed entirely it's going
to be moved over here to the right so
it's going to be like so you might like
to put this in as well okay I've got a
new H but alow with that new H I also
have a new X where is X in this diagram
have a look where would you place it
it's just like teeny tiny little length
over here right and that's actually very
important that it's getting teeny tiny
this new X over here you can see as
theta gets smaller as I move this radius
down even further let's go down like
this in fact at this point here I'm
going to draw one more and probably on
your diagram you'll not have much space
to do any further than that
like that as theta gets small what's
happening to X it's just vanishing away
right as theta disappears at theta
approaches zero so does X so I have a
way of stating this right wrong color I
can say using my language of limits
right I can say but the limit as theta
approaches zero of that length X what is
that limit what's it approaching what
are we just established also approaching
zero right so therefore if I think about
this in the context of this statement
that we just made over here about H
right we've forgotten that it was about
H we don't need to know that that's
where it came from but that's where we
learned this right just simple right
angled triangle tree I can take the
limit of both sides here as theta as
theta approaches zero right in other
words for small values of theta this is
what happens when theta is approaching
zero we say they're getting little right
I'm going to have our sine theta on the
left hand side what's going to happen
over here
what's happening to that ex we just
established this right that X is just
vanishing away it's just disappearing
right so these things are going to
become equal to each other without that
X you see what happened that was like
our mine is zero and it's just vanishing
away okay now you can see here ours just
the length of any description so I can
divide both sides through by a so I'm
getting this like so okay now sine theta
and theta what are we saying as theta
gets smaller and smaller and smaller the
difference between them is really this X
and that's getting smaller and smaller
and smaller and smaller you can see that
these things are approaching each other
for small values of theta
what does idea actually approach when
theta gets small think about the graph
what does feature sorry what does sine
theater approach when theater itself
gets small it also approaches 0 if you
have a look at the graph there right as
theater approaches 0 as it gets closer
and closer into the origin right do you
see that theater is getting to 0 so is
sine theta right that's him just an
approach when you are getting closer to
0 same thing right here's the graph
actually not interested in this part
over here but this just so you recognize
it as 10 and as you can see as theta
gets closer and closer to 0 in this
little territory in there right you can
see 10 is getting closer and closer to 0
in other words theta and sine and tan
they're all approaching 0 does this make
sense ok so what we can state is in
summary for small values of theta sine
theta and theta and tan theta up or
basically the same thing this is the
small angle approximation after which
this entire idea is named for small
angles we can approximate these things
as all basically equal to each other